well how did you how did you start off
writing though what was the like what
was the decision to get into but i
wasn't writing i was just creating
characters ah
okay like my character stuff um would
come out of my silliness honestly like i
was such a storyteller like i i don't
know that i do this you when i do it
with you you play along absolutely um so
it's always like a different voice like
it's this accent it's this voice i'm
telling a story you're telling you are
the person you're telling the story
about and like that's just what it is
always in a bit it's i it can't help it
um
i didn't realize i did that but like i
started to realize i did that when my
mom would try and do it back
no i was like what are you doing yeah
she'd be like what are you doing i'm i'm
doing what you're doing and i'm like no
no i'm not it's really weird you're
taking me out of the thing it's not
funny anymore you're doing anything cool
that's weird
mom
okay
but this is amazing actually
so i made so one christmas
my mom had given me a high eight video
camera
i had no money my version which was i
had my mom's credit card my rent was
paid but i had no money okay okay um so
i could go to the gas station or the
market with the credit card and like you
know get some chips and [ __ ] but that
was like my so that's my version don't
get me wrong i understand i come from
privilege okay
um
so one christmas i was like what am i
gonna do so i stayed up until like three
o'clock in the morning playing dress-up
and doing all these different characters
wishing happy holidays
so like there was the drunk french lady
there was mara me ver who i still do
there were all these characters just in
your head in my head playing dress up
make up the whole thing
and
video like did the whole thing edited it
and sent 52 vhs copies out to friends
and family and maybe two people in the
industry it was not to get a job it was
literally this is a shoe happy holidays
yeah at the end is having holidays i was
like drunk at the end pretending
one had gone to one of my cousins and we
all went home for christmas after that
and i'm in the kitchen and you know that
face your mother gets when you know you
are in trouble oh yeah she it got to her
she said tracy yes i'm gonna talk to you
can i talk to you come upstairs i was
like i'm like this isn't even i want to
talk to you and we're in the kitchen
like i need to go upstairs to the
bedroom
she sits down on her bed next to me she
has she does the
sit down next to me and i was like
what and she said
how many people have you sent that video
to
[Laughter]
i said 52 yeah 52.
can you get it back and i was like what
do you mean she was like
i think to her it looked like it was a
comment on her parenting
like it looked like it looked like you
were yeah like i had got but it was the
beginning of my career yes
you